a new era has begun for Cristiano
Ronaldo following his high profile split
with Manchester United the free agent
has now signed one of the most lucrative
deals ever with Saudi Arabia's al-nasa
at his press conference he didn't speak
to the press and only took questions
from a club official
welcome Cristiano thank you in Europe my
work it's done I
I won everything I play in the most
important clubs
in Europe and for me now it's the new
new challenge what are you hoping to
achieve on and off the pitch in Saudi
Arabia in Brazil in Australia us even in
Portugal's many Club
try to to sign me but
I give the word to this club for the
opportunity to develop not only the
football but the other part of this
amazing country
Ronaldo's salary is the highest in
football history around 206 million
dollars a year which boils down to 25
000 an hour seven dollars every second
he's the best player in football history
so it's normal he becomes the player
with the highest salary in the world
there's no doubting Ronaldo's commercial
pulling power thousands turned out to
welcome the five-time Ballon d'Or winner
in Riyadh our NASA shirts are selling
around the world and the club's
Instagram account has jumped from 800
000 to 8.8 million followers in just a
few days
it's a boost for Saudi Arabia's football
league and the hope is that other big
names will follow who knows maybe that
we might get in messy maybe uh Zlatan
Ibrahimovic any any of these players
that we would normally see go towards uh
previously China previously or previous
or until now to the United States of
America is for the MLS they could be
coming towards uh Saudi Arabia to play
football
on NASA a nine-time Saudi Champions and
with Ronaldo on board they're now surely
favorites to make it 10. leaving my best
like all of them he's set to make his
Club debut on Thursday David Stokes LG
zero